SPEAKER 1: Now we are going
to move on to our responses
from a couple of distinguished
professors at Harvard.
First is Erez Manela,
Professor of History.
And then Peter Der Manuelian,
the Philip J. King Professor
of Egyptology will follow.
And then we'll take
your questions.
EREZ MANELA: Well,
thanks to the organizers
for inviting me to do this, and
thank you all for being here.
I think the perspective
that I can offer
will be very different
from that that you just
heard from the editors because
I don't have their experience
in receiving manuscripts
and don't generally
have the vastness of their
experience in the publishing
world.
What I can say is based
on my own experience,
having published my
dissertation book in 2007,
having some other dealings with
publishers over other projects,
and speaking to
colleagues and friends
about their own experiences.
And the one thing that has
struck me with that experience
is how diverse and how
different these experiences can
be across disciplines, across
fields within a discipline,
and among different presses.
So for example,
to give an example
with the divergence
between disciplines,
I don't know much
about linguistics
but my impression of monographs
in linguistics that I have seen
is that they tend to be
full of specialist jargon.
They tend to speak to
a very narrow audience.
And yet, at least those
that I've seen obviously
got published.
I don't know, of course,
how many got rejected.
But it seems at least
within that discipline,
the norms of
monograph publications
do call for that type of format.
Now on the other
hand, within the field
of history, which
is my own field,
I have seen people publish their
first books, their dissertation
books, with trade publishers.
And in fact, I have seen
one of my own colleagues
win the Pulitzer Prize
for their first book based
on their dissertation.
It's not common.
I wouldn't expect it, but
it does, it does happen.
And in fact, within
the fields in history
that I am most closely
associated with, that is,
Modern American history,
Cold War history,
international
relations, I think there
is quite a good
chunk of first books
that get published with trade
presses, with Random House,
with Blackwell, several others
that I could name if I gave it
a few minutes of thought.
But it's not that rare.
There's also a diversity
among institutions.
I think there are
different institutions,
different departments, view
publishing your first book
with a trade press differently.
And so whichever department, or
institution if you're from MIT,
you're in, try to get a sense
of what your colleagues might
think about your choice to
publish with a trade press.
In some contexts, it might
be seen as a poor decision.
In other contexts-- certainly
if it wins a Pulitzer Prize,
and that book was
published by trade press,
I forget which one,
but by a trade press--
it might be seen as
a brilliant decision.
Now even within the scope
of university presses,
there are significant
differences
I've found by talking to
people who have published
in different presses and by
reading books that have been
published in different presses.
So for example, while some
presses will never publish
footnotes, that is, the
notes that are actually
at the foot of the
page, and will rarely
publish bibliographies,
other presses
regularly publish footnotes
and almost always publish
bibliographies.
And so depending on what kind
of book you want to publish
and on who you think
your audiences are,
it really pays to
do your research
on the different presses, to
look at books that they have
published recently
in your field,
and to see if just in terms
of the format of the book--
footnotes versus endnotes,
art versus no art,
bibliography versus
no bibliography,
length of the book,
and so on and so forth,
design-- whether these are,
this is the sort of format
that you imagine for your book.
And if you do that
kind of research,
I think you'll be
much, much happier
and perhaps have much quicker
success in the process
of finding a publisher.
I've heard before from a
number of editors the advice
of eliminating jargon.
Certainly some presses
emphasize that.
On the other hand, for
example Duke University Press,
I haven't seen a single
book they've published
that isn't full of jargon.
And so again, there's
a significant amount
of diversity.
With regard to length,
yes, 100,000 words
is a common recommendation.
On the other hand, and
I've just now finished
a-- in parentheses, I teach
a lot of what we call,
to my graduate students
and occasionally even
to undergraduates, what
we call first books.
First books, that is, books
based on dissertations
because I think
graduate students
have a great deal to learn
from reading books that
are based on these sort
of intellectual projects
that they are beginning
to be engaged in.
And so I read and have
read recently, first books,
not just in my own field but
in a number of other fields.
And so we just taught a book
called Gay New York, which
was published in 1994.
It was based on a
dissertation, is a major,
still considered a
major contribution
to American history, to queer
history, to gender history,
and is at least twice as long as
the recommended 100,000 words.
I can easily think of four
or five other examples,
recent, more or less,
recent examples that
are much longer than that.
My own book,
incidentally, is not,
just because I don't like
to write a great deal.
I prefer to say
things succinctly.
But there are contexts and
there are ways in which you
need to say things at length.
You need to have
thick descriptions.
And some presses
do publish books
that are significantly
longer, do take a chance
on books that are significantly
longer if they think they're
important enough, if they think
they will sell significantly,
if they think they'll
be taught in classrooms,
go into a backlist
where, 16 years later, people
are still teaching them
in courses.
And so I don't
know what exactly,
what set of judgments
editors have
in deciding whether to take a
chance on a book in that way
or not.
But certainly just
looking at things
that have been published
more or less recently,
you can see a great diversity
of formats, of lengths,
of shapes, forms, sizes.
Now with regard to
getting a contract,
approaching a
publisher, again, I've
found, at least
in my discipline,
a significant
diversity among fields.
It's fairly common
for me when I talk
to people in fields
that are considered,
I suppose, by presses a
less marketable-- let's
say, I don't know,
medieval Russian history--
that they experience,
it's just an example,
that they have significant, it
takes them a significant amount
of time to find a publisher.
And it's not an easy process.
I've rarely come across
a colleague, you know,
who's at Harvard
or has graduated
from Harvard, who did not
manage to find a publisher ever.
That's despite trying.
But it can be a long and
can be an arduous process.
On the other hand, and
I think, and I actually
would like to pose this as
a question to our colleagues
here from the presses, my
sense here is that in general,
and again, there are
differences between presses,
in general, academic presses,
university presses, have,
are more reluctant
now to publish
what they see is narrow
monographs than they might
have been 10 or 20 years ago.
On the other hand,
there's a flipside.
They're more eager, I think
now, to publish things
that they think will have
a substantial market.
So what that has meant for
people in American history,
in Cold War history, again,
which is fields that I know,
are fields that
I know very well,
is that we are finding it very
easy to get publishing offers.
In fact, we oftentimes--
and I've heard this,
I've experienced
this myself, I've
heard this from
others-- we don't
need to approach publishers
because publishers approach us.
They somehow hear
about the projects
and they send us
inquiries about,
would you be interested
in sending me
a chapter or a proposal or
something along these lines.
Quite a few of my
colleagues have
been approached by literary
agents, again, out of the blue
because they've heard
about their projects.
I've so far myself have resisted
that temptation for reasons
which I can discuss in the
Q&A if anyone is interested,
but quite a few
of my colleagues,
again, in the fields of Cold
War and Modern American history,
do have literary agents
and do publish through
literary agents, sometimes
placing their books
in university presses,
sometimes placing
their books in trade presses.
And they have
found agents to be,
so you probably didn't
want me to mention agents
in this context.
I know it's a freighted,
it's a freighted issue.
But they find them especially
useful in that part
about negotiating that
Phillip just mentioned
at the tail end of his talk.
And while it's true that on the
whole, publishing with an agent
is more common in one's later
books, not the dissertation
books, I can think of,
again, quite a few examples
of colleagues who
have had an agent even
with their first book.
So again, there's a great deal
and great degree of diversity
in this experience, I've found.
And I'd like to keep my
remarks short so I'll end here.
I'm eager to hear what
questions you have
and to respond to your concerns.
PETER DER MANUELIAN:
Shall we move on to me?
Or, OK.
Great.